yeah yeah so I couldn't make it to that
meeting this morning I had some Google+
like Google+ will give me issues with
that
I'm gonna go ahead and get started and
I've been given the job of introducing
Ryan here so you guys know the speaker
okay Ryan's now a second-year PhD
students and he came through the
University of Wisconsin and graduating
genetics there and since then he's done
some work you know both in academic
centers and also in industry involving
basically two 'men genetics statistical
genetics a little bit of population
genetics and he's gonna be talking about
some work that's gonna lead into his
dissertation involving retinopathy of
prematurity which is an eye disease and
the genetics behind this disease so
right I'm gonna let you have a go at it
so I'm gonna be talking about this
disease mostly today this is a study
that we're working on to try and
identify genetic causes that are
associated with retinopathy of
prematurity which is a disease that
affects premature infants and we haven't
gotten all the way through to the data
analysis stage this is gonna be a little
bit truncated when we we set up this
meeting I'd already been kind of hoping
that we'd be getting through to that
point so really this is mostly just
going to be about the disease and kind
of what what makes it up how we look at
it and then talk briefly about some of
the candidate genes that were involved
in picking out right now before we go
forward with the study so first off this
disease is an eye disease and it is a
very common cause of blindness in
infants and historically it's been
linked with oxygen overexposure a lot of
infants earlier before we had
subcutaneous oxygen monitoring were
affected with this and since we've had
more advanced
technology for monitoring oxygen and
infants it's become a bit more
controllable but as technology has
gotten better for keeping premature
infants alive we have more premature
infants and more severely premature
infants and so incidence of disease is
still pretty high it was the most common
cause of blindness and in the 40s and
50s is it still the highest cause of
blindness an infant sitter the highest
so it's still a major major concern and
it's still something that we'd like to
find some sort of way to treat better
than we have already or at least ways to
figure out what the important risk
factors are so what is written off via
prematurity so the main thing is that
the normal vascular ization procedure
that happens in developing infants gets
interrupted in some way and you see this
area at the top of the eye the superior
side doesn't get the normal formation of
blood vessels that you would normally
see and then over time that procedure
picks back up again and you see the
formation of this this Ridge of vascular
tissue and then that process if it's
left untreated and can cause the the
retina at warp or become disfigured in
some way or to be pulled entirely off
back I and
one of the things that has informed
treatment of this is that we can we can
see that the undeveloped tissue seems to
excrete some kind of vascularization or
angiogenic factor which causes greater
formation of these blood vessels and
then kind of exacerbates this problem
worse so ways that we break this down
and we say what are the actual features
of the disease how are we going to grade
this and say how how bad is this what
are the different cases what's the scale
reviewing it on one of the main ones as
we look at Sohn which is described as
different regions of the back of the
retina where zone one is centered around
the macula the center kind of blind spot
area in your eye and zone 2 is a larger
subsection zone 3 is farther out and you
can see that it's all kind of pushed
towards the nose side without blind spot
is and in general the closer in that
you're observing disease the worse it is
because that means that you're kind of
the process of pasteurization was
interrupted earlier and is closer to the
central field of view of the eye which
is more important there's a more
sensitive section for vision also
described this by the clock hour that
you observe it so you can look at the
eye as being a clock face and they've
got the three six nine twelve on there
so you can say that you have different
clock sections that have disease and
then that comes into the way that
ceases graded on severity another way is
we look at the stage of disease which
looks at how the formation of this Ridge
progresses you can see that the higher
stages have to do with basically kind of
a raising of this Ridge and the more
exactly like a more robust entrenchment
of it like you get more vascular ization
along in and it basically becomes more
pronounced that description has also
been expanded to talk about the actual
retinal detachment as a stage and so you
can see kind of in this figure how the
the disease can progress in the more
severe cases which caused the the retina
to actually be pulled entirely off the
eye which clearly is not something that
we would like to see once you get to
this point there's really no no
treatment available you're kind of stuck
with what you got and that's kind of the
worst case scenario
another way is there is also a
designation of whether you see something
called plus disease or not and plus
disease is subscribed by having more
tortuosity in the blood vessels which is
kind of like wine deenis or twist enos
and you also see this increased blood
flow which I think they described is a
more florid pattern so you can kind of
see these are both actually plus disease
examples but the bottom one is a more
severe version of plus disease than the
top one so you can kind of see that you
have that progression where you just
have a lot more blood flow flow
happening you've got a much more it's
less less straight lines more twisty
lines basically and then this has also
been extended since it turns out that
plus disease is a really really big
indicator of whether he's in treatment
or not there's been extension of that to
pre plus disease which is kind of a
precursor to plus disease or a lower
version of plus disease which also is a
pretty good indicator of whether
treatment should be necessary or not
so what happens if you do any treatment
so we have threshold disease which is
kind of once you passed that point it
becomes fairly likely that the disease
is going to continue progressing until
it's treated or resulting in some sort
of attachment or blindness and what we
look for there is you're looking for
stage 3 disease which was that really
pronounced Ridge in zones 1 or 2 so
close to the center of the eye in the in
the field of vision and you're looking
to see if you see the disease and five
contiguous clock zones or in eight total
Fox owns and then also the president
does all those things are pretty good
indicators for a lot of these cases it
was 90% of cases it'll get better in
general but in about ten percent of the
cases that continues to progress so once
you identify an infant as being one
that's going to require treatment you
get into different ways of treating it
and historically what they used was
cryotherapy to kind of cauterize that
undeveloped area of on vascularized
tissue prevent it from releasing these
angiogenic factors and that would kind
of halt the progression of the disease
that was not great for the eye it's a
pretty pretty brutal treatment for the
tissue and results in a lot of scarring
now we're able to do that with laser
therapy which is a little bit better but
still results in scarring and still
doesn't allow the disease to kind of
regress
it's basically a an endpoint change so
once it gets that point those two
treatments have shown really bad
outcomes long term in terms of the
visual acuity like you may not be fully
blind but you may be legally blind in
majority of those cases but it's treated
that's really just kind of the best
approach so far currently there's
clinical trials I think this is still in
clinical trials for drugs that are
angiogenesis inhibitors and so they
prevent that angiogenesis from happening
and early results there are some
problems with diagnosing the disease and
recognizing infants that are going to
require treatment first off is that
there's not a ton of people who are
experts in diagnosing this disease and
the availability of people who are
experts expert diagnosticians for this
makes it more difficult to to identify
those cases early and identify them
accurately and then there's also the
problem of subjectivity in a lot of
diagnosis where especially in cases of
Plus disease it's very difficult to say
like here's a border like exactly beyond
this point before this point is so
because of those things it would be
really nice if we had some sort of a
test that we could administer that was
less subjective and that took a lot of
the guesswork out of this and so because
of that the study is looking at doing
imaging and being able to see if there's
a way to sort of form an automated and
more empirical way of picking up on what
what cases are beyond that threshold
disease and the part that we're more
interested in or that we're more I'm
more involved in is the genetic
components of disease so if we had a
genetic test that we could administrator
and say like yes this is an individual
that's at high risk and they could be
monitored closely longer more effort to
kind of identifying who those patients
are and then tracking through the
process and hypothetically you could
also find some way of treating it that
would more directly address so when
we're looking at targets one of the
other things that we look at are what
other diseases are similar to this one
and there's a syndrome called Eva which
is very very close in its phenotype to
the prematurity and that has some
genetic research done in it already
because it's x-linked so it's a little
bit easier to identify and Noorie
disease is another is where z is another
one that has some genetic basis and then
diabetic retinopathy and age-related
macular degeneration are two other
things that we're looking at for
candidate genes to try and figure out
how the mechanism of happy premature he
could work
so specifically a lot of the major
players that seem to come up are these
angiogenic growth factors which isn't
super surprising this betcha the
vascular endothelial growth factor comes
up a lot and is one of the main things
that's seems to play a role on all three
or all four of these different diseases
and there's already some work like I
showed before into these anti-angiogenic
factors that has yielded some some
possible drugs for that target and then
igf-1 insulin-like growth factor there's
another one that comes up a lot it's
actually a really good predictor of
whether retina papillote prematurity
will and another one and then there's
there's a few groups of signaling genes
that are also implicated and one big
family of them is this went family of
genes which is involved very closely in
the fever disease and there's been a lot
of studies in mouse on these genes but
not in humans that seem to show that
they could be responsible for some
degree of risk
BPO kind of the same thing there are
some disease or some genes that are
specifically linked with fever and/or
disease that have shown
they've been investigated and I've shown
some sort of not super strongly but of a
fair link it ones this R is for gene
which I think they've identified as
possibly being responsible for something
like five to 15 percent of the variation
in in maturity and then other ones that
are involved in the same pathway well
and there's a sort of a whole group of
other genes that seem like they're a
little bit more all over the map and a
lot of these are are involved kind of in
different kinds of signaling or DIF
different signaling pathways that are
kind of tangentially connected these and
these are all except for I'm not sure
about the extracellular molecules but
the rest of them have been in Mouse and
rats so taken all together this seems
like a pretty good relatively cohesive
group of genes that could form some sort
of a basis for this disease but it's
it's a pretty big group and then you're
also dealing with a lot of other things
that aren't genetic in nature that we we
are going to have a harder time
correcting for like environmental
factors so the sample as it stands right
now we have three hundred and fifty
infants that are followed for the first
year and we have clinical data and
imaging data and genetic data on those
infants so the genetic strategy or assay
that we've been talking about let's do
whole exome sequencing and then do snip
chip in addition to that
more of the regulators and promoters and
other adjutant like kind of other
involved factors that might be involved
in this that we wouldn't pick up with
just by looking at the whole exome data
that gets a little bit more complicated
because for a lot of these infants we
don't have complete data so we may have
some of these things but not all of them
together so looking at the patient's the
way that we have to try and figure out
full who gets sequenced who doesn't get
sequenced is that we have to look at
who's the most likely to develop disease
that doesn't develop disease and the
ones that are least likely to develop
disease that do develop disease so
you're kind of taking two extremes of
the distribution and then we're going to
be trying to compare those to each other
for differences and that turns out to
have to do with basically being low
birth weight and low gestational age and
the ones that are higher birth weight
and have a higher gestational age which
makes sense like the ones that are more
premature are going to have more
problems in general and are going to be
more at risk for this disease and the
ones that have higher weights and are
are older or that have a more close to
full term are going to be less likely to
develop this so then you're just
basically looking at who in that low
risk group doesn't develop it in the
high risk group
so there are some other things that we
have to think about to make sure that we
can detect first off that there is an
effect even if we we have the data
because as far as power goes we were
looking at this data and there's going
to be like I said it's subjective not
all these infants were diagnosed by the
same people so how far can we trust that
diagnosis especially in the case of we
don't have imaging data on some of them
and then we also have to deal with the
fact that we may not necessarily have a
huge number of severe cases in either
group and because of that it's going to
be more difficult to try and get a big
enough sample that's going to be fully
representative of only the most severe
cases so we might have to pull from less
severe cases in both sides of tale and
then another big one is just that
there's a lot of environmental effects
and there's a really big big effect to
like say we have we have a population of
infant's that are from hospitals in
Mexico and I think we were talking about
it they said some of them don't even
they don't have blenders for the air on
on some of these incubators and so we're
kind of comparing two different
technology levels some of these samples
so we have to make sure that we narrow
this down to a sample where the
environmental factors are at least
minimized in some way that when we look
at this we don't end up paying too big
of a price on power and we're still able
to find some sort of
and the final thing is that it looks
like from what's come out so far that
there are differences between different
populations that are pretty big for this
disease so we have to make sure that we
can get kind of a little bit more of a
homogeneous group of patients or at
least if we're going to compare
different groups from different racial
backgrounds then we have to be kind of
aware of that we have to have a big
enough sample from each of those groups
that we think that's really all I have
right now that's kind of where we've
we've ended up we're waiting for you to
come back now and then we're going to be
moving forward with the sequencing
analysis question
in this case I mean we're we're hoping
that there's gonna be an underlying
genetic factor to these things that's
hopefully not really involved in the
environmental side of things like
because of that we're hoping that we can
find a sample that's big enough that we
kind of say that yes these all have the
same environmental effects so that we
can kind of rule that out but I mean so
one thing I know the IGF levels there's
I think it's by GF that spikes before
birth and so there are some signaling
things and some difference processes
that happen that seemed to indicate that
this could also be something with
interrupted development phases that
might have it
you might have said this and I I might
have missed it did you say is the
sequencing going to be performed only on
the infant's okay cuz because there are
genetic Association methods that are
family based that get around that
problem of population yeah they're not
affected by population structure so it's
it's kind of nice when you have a really
mixed group but it also means that you
need at least double or triple the
number of sequences we'd thought about
trying to collect blood from parents
David just because of the exact reason
you're mentioning but you know I thought
it was just logistically it's
logistically pretty hard to do that
because you've got a crack down both
family you know both parents in the unit
so just opted against that you just
decided to get blood from the babies but
you know we're stuck with exactly the
problem you mentioned well eigen strat
is worth looking at not that's a method
that adjusts for population structure
but doesn't depend on having parents
with these babies how are they typically
diagnosed to receive preventive
treatment and of course of the disease
so we have and like kind of end to end
data and they have exams of read
we have pretty regular exams throughout
that period I was curious because
whether your method improves over the
existing approach or not yeah I'm not
sure like how how is that sorry given
that do you know what the error rates
are for I guess human classification
yeah there are some studies into
agreement between people that are kind
of describe what we're kind of expecting
as far as a disagreement between the
Raiders but it's it's harder to do that
when we don't have imaging data for them
and I think that that might be be
something that we run into because we
don't have imaging data on all these
babies but if we did then there would be
a more concrete way to kind of have the
computer grade a mall and then set your
threshold that way
it's there's gonna be a difference of
opinion and that certain percentage is
probably closer to 25 than to - you know
for example it's a problem if we're to
sort of you know any sort of amount and
this comes up all the time in terms of
computer-based decision support and
stuff like that how you're gonna
validate that ties into the stuff that
Ryan's doing which is that if you get
someone to do a clinical diagnosis and
if you get someone you know one person
to look at the picture and two people to
look at the picture three people look at
the picture and if you combine their
aggregated opinions it'll converge on
what the most likely sort of correct
answer is
have you identified any confounding
conditions that would kind of mess up
your your initial kind of stratification
of low birth weight versus high birth
weight because there are some pathologic
conditions that result in high birth
weight I don't know if there's an
association with retinal diseases but
this think about know specifically about
high birth weight but I know that it's
you know it's something we're aware of
and it's going to have an impact on it
but it's as far as the cases that
develop the retina Pott retinopathy of
prematurity my understanding is that
phenotypes pretty strong so we can kind
of trust that diagnosis I don't know if
there's any others
but you know I don't know I mean in
terms of that you know these so-called
outliers you know the so you know Ryan
helped sort out you know do you see in
general if you're a baby and if you're
small and if you're sick you're likely
to get disease if you're big and you're
healthy you're not likely to get disease
and you know we've sort of found a
hundred babies who were either big and
had disease or small I did not have
disease and so they presumably have some
protective or risk factor and as far as
we can tell we look at all the
traditional risk factors and didn't find
much difference between them and so
we're sort of assuming that they had
some free disposition to make them you
know at risk or protective and you know
do whole exome sequencing on those and
that'll be sort of
good question to you guys we just got
off a conference call this morning about
this and I I think that what's really
neat about this from an informatics
perspective is that people like regular
clinicians have characterized this
disease for you know probably forty some
years you know all these clinical
studies you know tens of millions of
dollars of NIH money important you know
characterizing who gets it how do you
treat it when you need a dream how do
you Massif I and all that type of stuff
why do people care because this stuff
that causes this disease it's blood
vessels growing in the retina and it's
because that type of pathway also costs
a lot of other diseases diabetic eye
disease macular degeneration cancers and
so it's not necessarily that so you know
why do people care about you know
several hundred premature babies every
year too because you can learn stuff
about them that affects a lot of other
people and you don't have to wait twenty
years for someone to get diabetic eye
disease so you get all that clinical
characterization and then you know we
get these images we sort of analyze
these images and you know this person
who many of you know Jason we company
Cramer you know is working with a group
that you know for some reason she moved
out to Boston you know a couple years
ago and and so she's working with her
and a group of people to characterize
those images and try to quantify various
features of them and then you know Ryan
with people like them all yeah do some
genetic analysis and at the end of the
day so that's a long prelude to my
specific question which is what they
want to do is to figure out what genes
are likely to cause this disease what we
can do with the clinical data and with
imaging data is figure out what are the
parameters that identify bad disease you
know your vessels are tortuous and we
can put a number on it and stuff like
that and at the end of the day what
we're hoping is to take these genetic
data and take those clinical data and
those imaging data together to create
some holistic models for disease and how
the clinical stuff integrates with the
genetic stuff integrates with the
imaging stuff using for that and what
data needs to go into that model I would
jump to the type of graphical models
that I was talking about the other day
where you can kind of see these
interactions between different risk
factors and genetic effects and measures
on the the images and tortuosity as a
measure or whatever you just think of
you have some joint distribution between
all those different effects and then try
to weed out the the connections that are
important based on data of course that
depends on whether you have a large
enough data set it's a problem yeah you
generally need a lot of data I mean it
sounds like from the start you're doing
a type of logistic regression and just
trying to see like with but you want to
control for these other factors and
whether you can throw in some of the
imaging like measures that you get will
the real trick is setting up what you
consider the phenotype and like you know
finding a good quantitative measure for
that and then trying to figure out like
how the factors relate to it I mean the
strength of graphical models is you can
really ask specific hypotheses and
whether they actually fit the data so I
mean it's
it can be a powerful technique but you
have to use it rate or something like
lasso regression where you have a lot of
different factors and you're looking for
kind of a small minimum set that is the
best predictive that's a way to yeah
that's kind of what I was thinking for
the genetic glasses you this seems much
more like hypothesis generation than
hypothesis testing to me have you guys
thought at all about you know the follow
up with this and what would you would do
next assuming you found you know some
you know significant associations and
that also gets into what you were
talking about Michael about you know
applying this to other diseases and so
some of that follow up could be in
studying those genetic effects of these
other eye diseases kind of research and
that's actually one thing that we argued
about a little bit in the call this
morning because I think that um let me
just digress for a second and say for
those in my opinion there's a lot of
question and in the bioinformatics
literature about whether we're moving
from hypothesis driven to hypothesis
generating research because of these
huge kind of datasets or maybe research
is getting to be kind of a combination
so our argument this morning went
something along the lines of should we
be defining certain so so Ryan came up
with this list of about 40 candidate
genes based on neovascular is based on
published literature involving
neovascularization and we're trying to
relate those
Jeanne's two different problems that
could go wrong in the blood vessels like
you know this gene affects the budding
of blood vessels or something and it may
affect this quantitative feature and so
we're trying to piece together a table
that links those types of things so the
biologists are pushing us to do exactly
that to do something that makes rational
sense and then we'll test that in the
model you know once we get the genetic
data to see if it really fits what's
happening so I guess in that sense it's
hypothesis-generating
all right it's hypothesis driven J
Cherie made the point on this morning's
call that shouldn't this table of
clinical phenotype imaging phenotype and
genetic phenotype be the result of the
study based on what the data show is
about what correlates with what and so
that's sort of the hypothesis driven
part and what we ended up with is that
it's a little bit of both because you
know you generate your questions from
that hypothesis driven stuff test to see
if it works and then you come up with a
result which may be you know what fits
the data or whatever and hopefully it
kind of makes sense that's a really long
answer yeah to say that it's hopefully a
little bit of you know both of those
things what do you think the answer has
to do with what again what you're gonna
do afterward I mean if you're really
trying to do you know hypothesis testing
you have to have an enumerated set of
hypotheses you have to correct for
multiple testing all that kind of stuff
I don't even know if you're gonna wind
up with a big enough sample size to you
know have enough you know enough
discrimination but you know if you look
at it from a hypothesis generation point
of view you can cast a somewhat wide net
because then you have a that implies
that there's a plan to follow this up a
lot of the hypothesis generation stuff
that I've familiar with in the
literature what they they kind of do
what you're doing is they create a
hypothesis from some sort of text mining
approach and then they go back and
review the literature to see if there's
if they can construct a story that
supports that conclusion based on the
existing literature you know maybe
there's a paper that's published that's
very similar or to the generator
hypothesis or it's a very similar
process in a different organ or a
related disease or something and they
sort of make this inference that you
know there's there's reason to believe
this might really be true and not just
some kind of statistical anomaly and
then you know but it can't ever end in
that because you don't actually know
anything you just know that you've got a
good question to ask so you know I don't
know if there are good disease no you
know Mouse disease models it seems like
there are because I've been some testing
and you can do you know gene knockouts
and different kinds of things that you
know really test that specific
hypothesis in kind of a causal way
because right this is all Association
and the Association doesn't imply
causality necessarily so I would go more
in the hypothesis generating direction I
just disagree and I tend to think alike
but in this way I think that one of the
I love this discussion and I think that
one of the challenges is that at the end
of the day what we'd like to do with
this is create some sort of tools that
are useful for real doctors and I think
that people will tend to believe things
more if there's a rationale for why it
why it makes sense now that said I I'm a
little bit a cynic all that I think
doctors often don't really know why they
make decisions or why they sort of do
things a certain way or they're probably
these patterns that go on in their minds
that you know they can't really
articulate but but I mean I think that's
an argument to try to you know for the
hypothesis driven stuff that it makes
sense to people but really I'm sort of I
think it would be great to be able to
you know have the j-series of the world
create diagnostic tools based on images
had to have the Ryans and the Kamal's of
the world create sort of diagnostic
tools based on based on genetic stuff
who's at risk and then at the end they
were going to try to put it together as
type 4 a genome enabled EHR you know
that combines the genetics with the
clinicals I mean I kind of look at that
as hypothesis-generating in that you
know the hypothesis that you're
generating is that you know this is a
good multimodal predictive model that
will be useful clinically and then so
you need another data set to validate
that model which is then hypothesis test
because the hypothesis that the model is
actually useful right so you know I it's
all sort of part of this process he's
obviously the difficulty and this is
getting enough data to do that it seems
to me like the hypothesis generation
makes more sense because there seems to
be like this
timing component of like when the blood
vessels stopped forming and if you can
hold them off for a little while then
they can reform so stuff that's just
about blood vessel formation genes that
just influence that it might have you
know they might be a more regulatory
aspect of which teams really have an
effect based on the timing of the
formation of these two separate things
especially since there's such a big
component for like environmental factors
and you know I think having a gene list
like you compiled with those 40 genes
could be really useful if you're looking
at like genetic interactions where
you're looking at combinations of genes
because in that case you know looking at
all combinations of 20,000 genes is
impossible yeah I can't do it but look
at all combinations of 40 genes like 2 3
4 combinations you can do that yeah